我现在呢是面临结婚对象的选择，然后现在有两个人选我呢，就是不是一个特别理性的人，就我想听听您的建议。嗯，就先说一下我的情况，我是已经35了，然后是县城的公务员，普通本科，独生女，有车无房，性格是比较内向，嗯，比较散漫的。然后呢，嗯，有点完美主义，有时候又特别没主见，有时候比较执拗，父母呢，是离异家庭，有退休，但是没有助力。下面说一下我两个择偶对象的情况，A是谈现任，谈了快两年了，然后B是前男友，谈了有八年。A呢，他是县城市直单位的妇科，比我小两岁，33。他是有一个短婚，一年未育，有这么个婚史。然后是性格不合，离婚，他是独生子，我们老家都是隔壁县级市的，他有拆迁的五套房，然后他的性格是属于那那种特别稳重踏实，就会比较处理家庭关系，觉得嗯，幸福的家庭比较重要，结婚生子才是完整人生这种观念。然后吵架呢，平时也都有他哄我，比较幽默，也做饭做家务，就是生日节日也会送礼物发红包这种，但这两年也不知道为啥胖了有三四十斤吧，还有经常腰酸背痛。
空这样，他问题是脾气比较大，就是原则性很强，但是消气也快，就相处这两年时，嗯，双方父母见过面了。他的父母是没有工作，属于比较朴实勤劳，平时就是干点零活，然后收收租。目前他们家也是在催婚，就刚开始的时候，我俩感情很好，他情商高嘛，然后又比较务实，就是我的生活包括工作，他都会比较照顾，然后花钱也不吝啬。
在就是相处一年的时候，跟我妈见面，然后闹了一次矛盾。因为我妈性格她比较强势，方面表示出了对他有过室的这个嫌弃，然后她自尊心又很强，很敏感，两人发生了点冲突。但这个事儿后面就是通过吃饭见面也解决差不多了。嗯，现在呢，我就比较犹豫结婚，他很喜欢孩子，然后想尽快结婚要孩子，就是包括我身体不好，我家里就是因为我妈弄那些虚拟币的负债情况，他都知道，然后表示可以接受。就是他觉得他坚定的选择了我，但是我却因为一些事情犹豫不理解他，和他不一条心，就觉得我在拖沓。这个是A的情况。嗯，然后B是我的小学同学，他呢和我同岁，家庭条件嗯一般，父亲有刑事案底，他有一哥已经婚育了，中学的时候，他辍学去上海打工。后面呢，一直是在北上广一些城市做那个公司的中层，靠自己努力，收入也还可以。现在呢，他是自己在老家开那个自媒体那种互联网的那种小公司，年收入大几十吧。就是我们在一起一共有8年多，北漂在一起有五六年，就前几年的磨合也比较痛苦，因为。
年轻的时候，我确实嗯对他不是特别喜欢那种。后来相处时间长了，就慢慢变好了，也变成了习惯，有种亲人的感觉。就最后，还是因为我家里强烈反对分手了。那当然，我本人肯定也是不太坚定，也是犹豫了好久，他就一直比较信任这段感情，就觉得我是闹着玩儿。因为就分手后，我们还能在一起，他和我就是性格爱好比较相似，然后时间久磨合的好，嗯，基本没太大矛盾，相处的比较舒服。然后分开后呢，他也是一直在等我，就是我告诉他我谈了对象，然后他也主动说他中间也是有过相亲一次，但是觉得你三观合适更重要。就这个年纪也不太好找那种三观契合的人，就是如果可以，也是想今年和我结婚，如果我同意，可以在我的工作的城市买房，然后开个小型的那种工作室过来。就是以上就是这个情况，分你还能帮我分析一下A他跟前任离婚的主要原因是什么？嗯，据他说是性格不合，那你有知道他前妻是谁吗？我知道他也是在我们同一个城市，他也是体制内的。嗯，那你对他前妻有所了解吗？就是前妻人怎么样啊？他好像就是性格比较。
嗯，尝试那种你有所了解是吧？我实话实说啊，你现在跟现任都已经谈了两年了，都已经同居了，就是谈8年的一个前任。他嘴上说不在乎，不在乎，不在乎，但以后日子也不好过。
嗯，去吧，不逛。我感觉你这个现任挺好的呀，家里面有5套房子，收租子稳定收租一个月能收多少钱呀？而且，他也是独子收租的话，就因为他们当时是卖了一套，然后现在也就出租了。你一年的话，嗯，六七万吧，就一年光收珠子就得六七万。你说到他和你妈妈因为什么事产生一点矛盾的话，我觉得你妈妈有很大的问题。
对他非常的强势哦，你妈妈我跟你说啊，我我可能这人有点偏见，对不起啊，你妈妈这把岁数了，还想着要暴富要炒虚拟币的话，那她就是有问题。对，而且这个我是这么想的，包括我旁边的朋友也这么认为。所以你以后需要做的是什么？远离你的妈妈和你老公关系，完了好好过日子，不要让你妈妈插手你们的夫妻关系，不要让你妈妈插手你的孩子教育，不要让你妈妈插手到你们小家庭当中来。你想你妈妈差点就给你干黄了对吧？对对，因为我也也是跟我妈大闹了一场，然后他才同意我们在一起，甚是你妈妈同不同意，你不应该把你妈妈同不同意这个东西放在一个呃很重要的衡量标准上，可能我太感性了，因为我觉得她身体也不好，我不想气到她就是住院什么的。你应该是那啥，要有一种捍卫自己小家庭的这样一个角色定位。是我现在现在就是希望我能够这个样子，他就觉得啊，我什么都只听我妈妈的，然后和他站在一起。
嗯，对呀，我感觉你的现任也应该是挺适合结婚的对象吧？又幽默又做家务，又有底子，又收租是吧？
因为他是比较适合结婚，就是平时就是他嗯，他照顾我，他做饭什么的，对呀，工作又稳定，又是个副科。
我感觉挺好的，他可能就是脾气这个问题哦。脾气这个问题，那你得跟他站一头啊。他意思就是他，他脾气大就是因为我，你确实该给跟你老公站一头。你妈妈不靠谱，我一听我就觉得不靠谱是吧？嗯，我我跟你说啊，正常要是希望自己的女儿好，哪有当面去说哎，你离过婚哎，我女儿对吧，陪你绰绰有余，哪有这么干的吧，就正常是一个有智慧一点的妈妈。就算说她不想你跟这个现男友在一起的话，她是不是应该是背着点儿应该给我女儿留后路？你不能让我女儿难难做人啊，你妈不靠谱，当面当面跟人家说，就是说那个我没想到我女儿找个那个结过婚的说出去不好听什么的。然后就是，然后，我男朋友就这一点上就开始还在忍着，到后面又说什么，如果你俩有了矛盾啊，我有我的办法，我意思我不会放过你这种就到这儿的时候，我男朋友就说了一句，就是两个夫妻两两口子有矛盾，应该是两个人都有问题。你不能说还没发生就都推到我身上。然后，他可能情绪有点激动，然后我妈就烦了。
少让你妈参与你的生活，以后你才有好日子过。嗯，然后我我再问一句，姐姐就是我，我选择现任的话，就是以后我们俩就是相处模式，就是不要让我妈去多干涉我们的生活。对啊，然后我还是脾气这话对他比较服软那种会比较好是吗？因为我，我其实也不太会说一些好听的话，实话说，我觉得男生的条件真的是不错的，就男生原生家庭的条件，自己的工作条件，自己又顾家又做家务又幽默，男生的条件挺好的，还是得珍惜吧，啊，就是这样，基本上婚后如果没有出现大样的变故，也不会说就突然变一个人什么的我还挺担心的，因为我觉得就是遇到各方面都这么好的，我还有点惶恐，你俩不都已经谈两年了吗？对是吧？那一般情况下啊，就是经济条件比较宽裕。像他就拆迁五套房，比较宽裕的人，他也不容易做什么极端的事儿。实话说，因为人家不愁找下家。
所以他不太容易出极端的事情啊，就是这个前男友，就是您觉得不用考虑啊，我觉得这日子不好过。你是他嘴上不说是吧？嘴上说他不在乎你俩都分手两年了，你都跟这头都已经谈婚论嫁到这程度了，你再跟他去过，我跟你说，他也就是没找到更好的。找到更好的早就早就跟别人过了，还轮着你啊，就是你那个谈了8年那个前男友，你要真跟他过的话，这日子又不好过了，你知道吗？
行嗯，好吧，好的，谢谢你。嗯，不是啊，拜拜，嗯嗯，拜拜。嗯，前男友那个心理吧，就是看着你要跟别人结婚了吧，心里面又觉得嗯，那是我的女人，曾经是属于我的，你真要跟他过了吧，这日子就不好过。